if you're training to be a pilot you
probably notice that pilots have to know
a lot about the weather one of the
biggest reasons for this is so we can
avoid hazardous weather in this video i
want to specifically talk about six
different hazardous weather conditions i
also want to explain when you should be
looking for them and tips to avoid them
in order to completely understand this
video you need to have a decent
understanding of the weather and what
causes it to change you might find this
video much more useful if you watch my
video on weather basics first if you
haven't already watched that i'll put a
card right here and a link in the
description then you can watch this one
afterwards the first hazard you really
need to know about is a temperature
inversion now this might seem confusing
because a temperature inversion means
that the air is really stable why would
that be so hazardous to a pilot that
seems kind of nice to me before we talk
about why that is let's briefly explain
what a temperature inversion is a
temperature inversion is when the
temperature actually goes up as you
increase your altitude as you may
remember this is not normal one way this
can happen is on a cool clear night when
there are no clouds to trap the heat
near the earth because of that the
ground cools varied rapidly and in turn
that cools the air next to it and leaves
the air to higher altitudes relatively
unchanged now we have warmer air above
and cooler air below another time this
can happen is in front of a warm front
as the warm air from a warm front pushes
into cooler areas some of the warm air
is lifted above the cooler air and once
again this causes an inversion the
difference between these two examples is
that on a cool clear night the inversion
happens near the surface on a warm front
the inversion can be at a high altitude
if it occurs a long way in front of the
warm front but as you can see the closer
you are to the front the lower the
inversion is now here's the problem as
we mentioned earlier in a temperature
inversion the air is extremely stable
this means that it's resistant to
vertical movement now while this does
mean that the air will be nice and
smooth there is another problem that we
run into when there's a lot of humidity
in the air that moisture tries to rise
but it can't because that warm air is
lighter and it traps that moisture at
low altitudes this can mean low clouds
fog haze or mist basically this causes
bad visibility and clouds at low
altitudes if you're a vfr pilot you can
see why this could be a problem but for
my ifr students this can also cause your
ceilings and visibility to be below
minimums and those need to be above
minimums in order to legally fly an
instrument approach okay so let's talk
about fog for a minute since we're on
the subject there are five types of fog
but four different types you should be
familiar with as a pilot radiation fog
is what you might get on one of those
cool clear nights where the moist air
near the ground cools rapidly as the air
cools if it's cool enough to reach its
dew point and it's not too windy
radiation fog will form and any wind can
cause radiation fog to dissipate because
of this you will often find it in low
areas like valleys between mountains and
hills where it can be shielded from the
wind advection fog is a little different
this occurs when warm moist air is
pushed over a colder surface the cold
surface cools the moist air to its dew
point which causes fog to appear this
sometimes happens in areas near the
coast during the winter time
as you may remember water cools and is
heated more slowly than the ground
because of this the air above the water
is typically warmer during the winter if
any wind up to 15 knots pushes that warm
moist air over the cool ground the air
will condense and cause advection fog
winds above 15 knots will often lift the
fog and turn it into low level stratus
clouds next we have upslope fog this
occurs when warm moist air is pushed up
a sloped area of the ground like a large
hill or mountain as the air is pushed up
it cools down and if it hits its dew
point once again fog occurs
this is a type of fog that can last for
days and can also appear at much higher
levels than most other fog one thing to
remember about upslope fog and advection
fog is that they both need wind to occur
next we have steam fog this occurs when
cold dry air is pushed over the water
that is relatively warmer as the water
evaporates it's cooled by the cool dry
air which causes it to condense and form
a smoky looking fog
this typically only occurs during the
coldest parts of the year one thing you
want to remember about steam fog is that
it's not uncommon to see icing
conditions and low level turbulence in
these areas okay so how can we avoid bad
visibility and low clouds caused by
these temperature inversions and frontal
systems first be aware of warm fronts
and avoid the leading edge as much as
possible you can know where these are by
taking a look at the surface analysis
charts and i explain these in a lot more
detail in some of my other videos second
if it's a cool clear night remember this
can cause low clouds and other types of
bad visibility consider planning for a
later takeoff third recognize coastal
areas and mountain areas when the
different types of fog can occur and pay
attention to the direction of the
forecasted wind
the second hazard i want to discuss
today is wind shear
wind shear is one of the scariest
weather hazards there is primarily
because it gets people when they least
expect it
wind shear is a sudden change in wind
speed and or wind direction that occurs
in a small area
these changes in wind speed and
direction can occur at any altitude
and the changes in wind direction can be
vertical as well as horizontal with that
in mind these changes can have a huge
impact on your aircraft's performance
for example if you remember from our
lesson on how an airplane creates lift a
wing needs relative wind in order to
produce lift the more relative wind that
flows over the front of the wing the
more lift the wing produces now let's
say for example you're landing in a 30
knot headwind at 500 feet and at 499
feet you only have a 5 knot headwind
this would be considered a type of low
level wind shear because the difference
is more than 15 knots now as you may
know your aircraft's approach speed is
typically 1.3 times vs 0 which is your
stall speed in the landing configuration
another way to remember this is so
stands for stuff out anyway my approach
speed is 60 knots that means my stall
speed is just above 46 knots if all my
flaps are in now remember our airplane
doesn't care about how fast we're
traveling over the ground it only cares
about how much relative wind is going
over the wings so if i have a 30 knot
headwind here and that all the sudden
drops to 5 knots and i don't do anything
my new air speed is 35 knots that's more
than 10 knots below stall speed if this
happens you just exceeded your critical
angle of attack and your airplane is now
on a full blown stall now you're
starting to see the danger of wind shear
and one of the reasons we practice stall
recoveries this type of wind shear where
the performance of our aircraft gets
worse is called performance decreasing
wind shear this can come in a few
different shapes and sizes you may see
this example that we just talked about
or you may see the wind shift from a
headwind to a tailwind and this can be
really bad you may also see wind shear
in the form of vertical air which can
not only push the aircraft up or down
but can also disrupt the airflow over
the wings which can destroy your lift
and ultimately cause the aircraft to
stall as well vertical movement of air
like this is typical in thunderstorms
and we'll discuss that more here in just
a minute but it's important to know that
the downdrafts a thunderstorm produces
can be in excess of 6000 feet per minute
and these are called microbursts and
thunderstorms can also create headwind
losses between 30 and 90 knots now some
types of wind shear can actually
increase the performance of your
airplane and we call this performance
increasing wind shear and this is what
would happen if you got a sudden
increase in headwind now this one's not
quite as dangerous as performance
decreasing wind shear but you still need
to look out for it sudden airspeed
increases can lead to you exceeding your
aircraft's airspeed limitations or even
exceeding the g limitations if you also
get into turbulence at the same time
okay so let's talk about some of the
things that cause wind shear and how you
can protect yourself the first thing
that can cause it is a temperature
inversion like we discussed earlier when
there's a temperature inversion if the
upper level winds are 25 knots or
greater it's not uncommon to see calm
winds close to the surface so this is
something to be aware of another place
you might find wind shear is near a
passing frontal system and this is for
two reasons first warm fronts can also
cause temperature inversion but also
there's typically a wind shift right on
the boundary of a passing front and this
can sometimes be significant so how do
we avoid wind shear obviously it's best
to avoid flying near thunderstorms and
frontal zones but the more you fly
you're probably going to find yourself
dealing with wind shear of some kind the
key to flying safely in windshear is to
one avoid bad wind shear at all costs
two
know where it exists if there's no way
to avoid it fly faster air speeds if you
know you're going to be dealing with
performance decreasing wind shear if i
know there's 30 knots of wind shear
right here fly 30 knots faster once you
hit that wind change you'll be right on
your air speed if it's a performance
increasing wind shear that's not quite
as big a deal just make sure you pull
the power back so you don't exceed any
limitations but now you're probably
wondering how to know where there might
be wind shear one of the first places
you'll see an indication is when you see
a remark like this on the taff or metar
in this example we can see that the wind
shear is at a thousand feet agl and the
wind is at 180 at 40 knots so if the
adis is calling winds at 180 at 10 knots
this is when i might consider carrying
30 extra knots of speed until i get
about 500 feet to be safe now you may
also see notes about windshear in the
pirates but one of my favorite places to
look is the winds of loft tables if
you're a regular viewer you know how
easy it is to find these take a look at
this line for the winds aloft near tulsa
as you can see at 3 000 feet msl the
winds are 180 at 28 knots if we looked
at the metar and the winds at the
surface we're calling calm then we know
there might be a little bit of a wind
shear here i highly doubt that to be the
case though since you could see that the
temperature decreases with altitude so
we know we don't have a temperature
inversion but notice here at tys we do
have a slight temperature inversion and
i'm not super concerned about wind shear
here either because the winds are only 5
knots at 3 000 feet
it's pretty rare to see winds increase
as you get closer to the surface i'm not
saying it doesn't happen but it's pretty
rare then don't forget about those
thunderstorms near these is where you'll
find some of the most hazardous
turbulence and wind sure there is so
thunderstorms are number three of the
big six weather hazards i want to talk
about today as we discussed in my
weather basics video
thunderstorms develop as a result of
warm moist unstable air warm moist air
creates a lifting force and the more
unstable that air is the stronger the
lifting force and the more powerful
these storms can be
now typically it's very common for
thunderstorms to develop in front of
cold fronts especially during the summer
time and that's because the air near the
surface is warmer and this causes two
problems first more evaporation which
adds more moisture to the air
water vapor is lighter than air so this
makes the air rise more quickly the warm
air near the ground also wants to rise
because it's lighter than the air above
it so now this lifting motion begins the
process of a thunderstorm's development
in the first stage these continuous
updrafts cause cumulus clouds so if you
see these you know you can expect winds
that are going to be pushing up on your
aircraft in the next stage we see that
the storm has developed into a
full-blown cumulonimbus cloud this is
what we call the mature stage these are
super dangerous for multiple reasons
first you can get some crazy
precipitation that can make it really
difficult to see also this is a stage
where you'll most often see the biggest
updrafts and downdrafts and as i said
earlier these downdrafts can be in
excess of 6000 feet per minute and this
is what we call a microburst and this is
that vertical windshear we were talking
about earlier anyway during this mature
stage of a thunderstorm there are a ton
of scary stuff to be aware of
first is lightning now technically it's
only a cumulonimbus cloud until there's
a lightning strike then it becomes an
actual thunderstorm but either way i'm
staying as far away from these as
possible because they can also cause
hail tornadoes gusty winds and wind
shear like we mentioned earlier last but
not least we have the dissipating stage
as a general rule dissipating
thunderstorms primarily produce
downdrafts but it's still something to
avoid as much as possible these can also
be very powerful and super dangerous
okay so now that we've talked about how
dangerous they are let's talk about
avoiding them first we know that we can
find these in front of frontal systems
especially cold fronts during the summer
time in fact it's not uncommon for huge
lines of thunderstorms to develop at the
leading edge of cold fronts
these are called squall lines and they
can be hundreds of miles long
thunderstorms at the leading edge of a
cold front can also be particularly
dangerous because they overtake warm
moist areas
this feeds them with fresh lifting
energy
one other way you can find out about
thunderstorms is called a convective
segment this is a type of in-flight
weather advisory that is specifically
designed to inform pilots of
thunderstorms in the area it can also
give you details on some of the specific
weather hazards associated with
thunderstorms these include storms with
surface winds greater than 50 knots
storms with hail three quarters of an
inch and greater in diameter tornadoes
and they can even let you know when your
flight instructor is going to be in a
bad mood okay well maybe not but they
should be able to do that but one more
thing they can do is they can also let
you know about embedded thunderstorms
these are basically thunderstorms that
are buried in other clouds and you won't
even know they're there because you
won't be able to see them so where can i
find these convective segments well one
way is to call and get a weather
briefing before you go fly they'll tell
you if one of these exists in the area
you're flying another way is to call the
fss on the radio and get an in-flight
weather briefing you can even know that
they exist before you call because atc
will often announce over the radio that
they're available on all fss frequencies
in the area attention all aircraft
convective segment for the tulsa
oklahoma area numerous embedded
thunderstorms reported north moving east
at 1 2 knots tops reported at 410
further information available on all
flight service frequencies now we know
there's a convective segment out near
tulsa and we can call the flight service
station closest to us and get the
details just like i explained in the
last video okay so now we know how to
find out where they are now we can avoid
them but let's talk about some ways you
can be safe if something crazy happens
and you accidentally get too close or
you mess up really bad and you actually
find yourself inside of a thunderstorm
because these things can literally pop
out of nowhere let's start by talking
about gusty winds what should you change
about your landings if you have gusty
winds well if they're gusty cross winds
one of the things you can do is land
with less flaps if you have enough
runway this is going to keep you from
getting pushed around quite as much your
flaps catch a lot of wind during
crosswind operations so this can make
things a lot easier if the winds are
straight down the pipe consider adding
half the gust factor up to 10 knots to
your landing speed if you're wondering
what i mean by that listen to these
winds from tower alright so here's
something handy that you can use
in the future
you can ask for wins without saying
anything else
say wins
win20017 gus six
in this example the gust is 26 knots so
i'll subtract my base wind speed from
that so our gust factor is nine knots
half of nine is four and a half so i'll
just round up and add five knots to my
approach speed and that just gives us a
little safety buffer when we make our
landings you'll find that if you don't
do this on gusty days roughly half your
landings will be plopped in and i
personally like smooth landings even
when it's gusty outside now let's say
you're coming in to land and the winds
are calm but there's a thunderstorm near
the airport depending how close the cell
is the smartest thing may be to divert
somewhere else but if the winds are calm
and it's far enough away you may still
be able to land but what runway should
you choose yeah the winds are calm now
but with a thunderstorm close by it's
something important to think about when
we look at how the downdrafts flow out
of a thunderstorm they typically flow
down and out so if you're going to
attempt to landing make sure you take
those potential wind gusts head on if a
thunderstorm is northwest of runway 3-1
i'd want to land on runway 3-1 not 1-3
because there's a potential that you
might see some wind gusts coming from
that thunderstorm any gusts you take
from the front will increase your
performance gusts you take from behind
will decrease your performance now let's
say you messed up and got yourself right
in the middle of a thunderstorm what
should you do your gut reaction may
actually tell you to do the wrong thing
if you ever get into this situation
typically the first thing you'll
experience is a performance increasing
headwind that is followed by strong
downdrafts then a performance decreasing
tailwind with this initial increase in
performance pilots have been killed by
pitching back down to chase their
altitude because immediately after they
are pushed straight down into the ground
by these downdrafts the big takeaway
here is that you should not chase your
altitude if this ever happens to you and
this is true if you run into really bad
turbulence as well focus on your
airspeed and fly as fast as you can but
still stay under your maneuvering air
speed this will help keep you from
damaging the aircraft then get out of
there as soon as possible if you hit a
downdraft like this your instinct may be
to pitch up to maintain your altitude in
reality this is the opposite of what you
need to do
pitch down and trade any altitude you
have for air speed this is going to
allow your wings to create more lift and
hopefully you won't stall
once you have enough air speed you can
climb away from the ground you're going
to need every bit of airspeed you can
get if you leave the cell with these
tailwinds anyway i hope you never need
this but it's something i wish
instructors would discuss more with
their students
the fourth hazard you need to be
familiar with is mountain wave
turbulence this is something that can
occur in mountainous regions in windy
conditions anytime the wind blows
through the mountains the ridges can
disrupt the airflow and cause really bad
turbulence on the other side the side
where the wind is coming from is called
the windward side any wind that hits the
ridge will cause turbulence on the
leeward side but the real problems
happen when the wind is 25 knots or
greater and the flow is nearly
perpendicular to the ridge
now this alone can cause some real
problems but when the air on the leeward
side is very stable or worst case you
have a temperature inversion this is
when you get true mountain wave
turbulence because any air that wants to
rise after being deflected by the ridge
is pushed down by that stable air and
this causes the air to rotate on the
other side
this becomes even worse when there's a
layer of unstable air below the stable
air because that can cause extremely
violent rotational winds on the leeward
side often in these conditions you'll
see these rotor clouds which can
indicate really bad mountain wave
turbulence to me these look like giant
cigars
anyway you don't want to be anywhere
near these things okay so there are two
other ways you can recognize mountain
wave turbulence before you even get
close first if clouds are beginning to
form on top of a ridge it's very
possible that warm moist air is being
pushed by wind up the side of the
mountain and that air is condensing and
causing clouds very much like upslope
fog
in these conditions this is where you
start worrying about mountain wave
turbulence if the air is stable if the
air is not stable this can be a problem
too because this is where you might see
a thunderstorm
one other way you can identify high wind
situations is when you see these
standing lenticular clouds these are
kind of smashed looking clouds that
would indicate winds that are 40 knots
or more so when it comes to mountain
flying fly on the windward side as much
as possible when the winds at altitude
are 25 knots or more or you see these
rotor clouds or standing lenticular
clouds or even if you just see normal
clouds at the top of a ridge this can
indicate that mountain wave turbulence
on that leeward side so that's really
when i'd be concerned about avoiding
that side our fifth weather hazard is
icing this is basically ice buildup on
your aircraft in flight this is scary
for a few reasons first it changes the
shape of the wings which can reduce lift
or change the angle of attack
second it adds weight to your aircraft
way more than you might think it also
increases drag on the aircraft and can
even cause engine problems ok so now
that you know that icing can occur
anytime you're invisible moisture and
the temperature is zero degrees celsius
or colder
invisible moisture can be clouds rain
snow sleet freezing rain basically any
form of water the worst icing you will
get though is if you fly through
freezing rain don't do it it's a scary
situation
freezing rain typically occurs ahead of
a warm front when the air that is being
overtaken is below freezing if you fly
through this you're going to see some of
the most rapid ice accumulation there is
one indication of freezing rain is ice
pellets i don't know if this is the
correct term but i call that sleet this
would indicate freezing rain at high
altitudes okay so how do i avoid this
first know the freezing level
as i explained in my video on prog
charts you can find the freezing level
and fly below it guess what you won't
get icing below that line you still need
to be careful about carburetor icing
though if you are going to be flying
through freezing temps just avoid
visible moisture all you have to do is
eliminate one of the ingredients for
icing and you'll significantly reduce
your chance of getting it one other way
you can know about icing is through
in-flight weather advisories the two
types that will warn you about icing are
air mats and sigmets
air meds primarily are for light single
engine aircraft they only tell you about
lower intensity icing
an airment zulu would be an indication
that you can expect moderate icing in
those areas
sigmets are warnings of bad weather for
all kinds of aircraft one type of
segment you would see is a warning for
severe icing and just like the
convective segments you can get these
air meds and segments from any flight
service station you can also find them
on the aviation cloud forecast as i've
mentioned in my past videos
one more thing i want to mention about
icing is that training aircraft have
very minimal anti-icing or de-icing
equipment in these aircraft you should
avoid icing to the max extent possible
as you begin to fly commercial aircraft
these may have anti-ice capabilities
just remember every aircraft can only
handle certain levels of icing never fly
into areas that are worse than the
airplane's capabilities but i would go
one step farther and say avoid icing and
get out of it whenever you can
light icing can turn into severe icing
in a matter of seconds
our sixth and final weather hazard today
is frost
this is something that happens on the
ground before you take off if you leave
your airplane outside overnight and
there's any moisture in the air when the
surface of the aircraft cools to the dew
point the air against it will condense
and form dew if the surface of the
aircraft is below freezing the dew will
turn into frost frost is dangerous for
two reasons first just like ice it makes
the aircraft heavier but more
importantly it disrupts the laminar flow
of the relative wind over the wing which
can destroy the lift of your wings and
you gotta have lift for your airplane to
fly so how do we avoid frost well one
way is to keep the aircraft inside at
night if you do leave it outside clean
off the frost especially on the wings or
just wait for the sun to melt it off i
hope this video makes you a safer pilot
but it wouldn't hurt to watch one more
video to learn something else you can
bring with you into the sky try this one
out and i'll see you over there